what's up party people whatever they
else trailer commentaries for Pokemon
the first movie Mewtwo strikes back I'm
supposed to join Gilbert
that's Joestar hi nobody else joined us
because Dan doesn't know enough about
Pokemon and Long's lunch break lasted
too long so we're in a rush we got a lot
of other things to do slash we hope
you're okay long oh yeah come back well
and soon we're gonna watch the Pokemon
honest trailer together and then we're
gonna comment on it give you some
behind-the-scenes insight into our pokey
thoughts and then we're gonna see some
pokey deleted scenes I'm not gonna keep
this going you should had a pokeball for
yeah Joe what's your pokey background
it's pretty minimal right yeah I don't
know crap about these I played the the
n64 game oh come on snap okay yeah I
played the arena game a little bit
because that's one of the only n64 games
we had for a while and Medora kid yeah
it was rough yeah
blitz stopped working and that's all we
had and I know that there is Digimon
different thing did my thing yeah and I
know that Pikachu eventually becomes a
rate there are digital pokemons and he
becomes a what now a rate you right he
was in right changing okay sorry so I'm
a Gen 1 guy I I definitely played
pokemon red I'm that old we plugged our
game boys together in the basement mmm
yeah and fought that's how you had to
fight back in those days when Mew got
released you had to stand in line at a
shopping mall to get the special Pokemon
yeah old stuff and then goes and undoes
that way like how many people saw this
and they're like the hell did I stand up
there for yeah so this was right in my
pokey sweet spot because after this if
you want to know anything post first
series first games I'm not you guy but I
knew enough to be dangerous for Pokemon
the first movie Mewtwo strikes back and
that said even though I was a big fan of
the game not a great film no terrible
yeah it's really pretty bad it's not
good it reminds me of like like a Disney
directed DVD or VHS sequel where like
like the second Aladdin movie was very
clearly three episodes of the TV show
yeah strung together to the point where
like they have very distinct times with
the credits for being it fails to black
it's another 20 minute adventure yeah
and it seems like this was just it
looked like the TV show it smelled like
the TV show it was the TV show but
longer yeah you know that and an
unhealthy Transformers obsessed sad
individual sure and I loved that
original movie but one of the reasons
why it sticks with you is because like
the animation had like a high budget
like it looks good elevated from the
original show yeah this is like you can
see like the commercial break moments
where it's just gonna cut to a still
photo of ash like who's that Pokemon
really do that in the movie which is
carryover from the TV show yeah not much
in the way of characterization I will
look it's got bright colors yep
it's got loud voices and noises and
pokey mount attacks I feel like this is
the definition of a movie that people
will defend to the death because they
saw it when there are little kids yeah
yeah it gets in there before your
critical faculties emerge and you know
that's fine
we all loved garbage I still do to this
day because we were too little to know
better
yeah and this is definitely in that
category I'm not a homeowner yet and I
am excited for it's a shame that you are
hopeless but it's also a shame that they
they haven't done more interesting
things with it in in other media and I'm
excited for detective Pikachu because
it's such a fun that doesn't they've
created and such a fun setting that they
just kind of stick to the absolute
basics and it is not grown up with its
audience right well they're making new
kids every day but still I've outgrown
Pokemon I'm sorry Jo
yeah let's poke you watch this thing I
choose it choose this I did not choose
this that's a line I know from Pokemon
before you pay is he detective Pikachu
revisit the first time he quick attacked
your wallet quick attacks and a pumpkin
them lights were in a child and now
we'll just embarrass your outer adult
the first movie you two strikes
[Music]
okay you got swept up in the Polka mania
the late 90s and if you didn't this
probably ain't for you chief because
they're not wasting any time explaining
what this place is who these people are
or why that cat is a Brooklyn accent do
we know nope okay I'm excited to see the
thousands of comments or top comment or
whatever be an explanation for that
followed by you [ __ ] [ __ ] I put that
in there knowing that I'm sure are very
helpful in supportive audience you guys
are cool better watching this but the
general the Internet in general will be
really kind and understanding what I
love about that Spencer is most of my
friends who I know who are super into
Pokemon are like super nice people and
like the fun sweet vibes of Pokemon like
sort of fit their personality they're
going through a big a sex abuse scandal
right now a lot of Pokemon twitch
streamers uh yeah so anyways you're
speaking about your friends like they're
taking advantage of the inherent
sweetness of the franchise I don't
approve of that good we have that on the
record go ahead Jeff like of all of the
franchises to turn into it you idiots
like a violent aggressive person like
this one really does not seem to fit
yeah I mean there's a darkness in
Pokemon like it we'll talk about that
one the shore but it's like it's like
getting really pissy with someone
because they messed up a name from like
My Little Pony Friendship is Magic I
like you I don't think you're
getting the point friendship is what's
really magic no accuracy
Joe is a not-so undercover brony so keep
going not sure about that one so if you
need a crash course on all things poke a
it's about child Runaways who make their
animal slink be each other unconscious
but don't worry they like it allegedly I
mean it is like they love to live in the
pokeball it's like a palace in there and
oh they love to fight they're very
competitive and simply that just
consider the source who are you getting
this from the people that stand to
benefit from them feeling man yeah that
is completely fair and they can't speak
for themselves they just saved the name
of what they are over and over again
with different inflections sometimes
yeah they're trapped in a Hell from
which they can't escape they have no
mouths and yet they must scream and yeah
you know like it seems like this was
like it's what big meat wants you to
think you know the cows greed they feel
no pain
yeah they feel nothing they feel what
what is the economy around Pokemon in
this world like Antebellum are their
Super Bowls yeah I mean WrestleManias
because there's like if if Wrestlemania
like the wrestlers also did all your
chores I know it's your dream but like
if you like bread John Cena's together
and all he could say was Cena and think
he had to wash your car because you beat
him and trapped him in a ball look at
how clean I got the shine you can see
you yeah but don't worry he likes it
keep going
meat that's a sideman idiot who's
constantly on the verge of death
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks mr. dice an idiot who's
constantly nagging and rock an idiot
who's constantly horny she's somebody
how old they're supposed to be I don't
remember
they make sense if they're eight
together with the bus I know a lot of
like eight and ten-year-old nieces and
nephews and stuff who are just like
she's hot and I'm like do you know what
that means and they're like yes what
does that mean eight year old and
they're like I got it no no I just mean
that the the general ABC of our three
main characters gotcha in general is
like yeah you know if they're 25 maybe
maybe it's a little I know they're not
25 I'm just gonna look up how old Ash
Ketchum is so I don't get yelled at
again hey guys hey Joe so here ash
ketchup does Pokemon mean to you let us
know in the comments how has it affected
your life he's 10 years old okay of
course he's an idiot he's 10 years old
yeah
that's fine yeah i rescind what we broke
all right keep going I think their
parents are awful for letting them just
go off and do this Japan's a safe place
this nutso Elite Four will bumble into a
secret fighting tournament slash world
domination plot that will make everyone
say
[Music]
Bravo laundry finding all these will be
your legacy
Alfie's hunt one he's not psychic claw
who's week two bug types and existential
crises he's got a plan to liberate
Pokemon from their human masters
that sounds pretty reasonable actually
until he starts killing everyone one of
he gets from siding with a villain who's
in the right got a killer mo see i'm
u2's planning this I thought was very I
was very sympathetic to it because he's
like he's uses the word he says Pokemon
your slaves I'm here to rescue you but
then they're like wait he can't be right
so we could say and I'll kill the
Pokemon - for allowing themselves to get
in this situation only the clothes mean
the clothes yeah you gotta push it yeah
there's that there's that line between
sympathetic villain and I'm on your side
villain yeah you gotta you gotta rack up
a bit of a body count to keep him as a
sympathetic yeah I do think that this
was like a surprisingly deep and kind of
interesting and nuanced character that
the rest of the film was completely
unable to deal with or handle or answer
in any no any guy would like why bring
up the meaning of life in the Pokemon
movie you're not gonna answer it isn't
he some guy's daughter's soul oh that's
the Japanese sub Virginia cool we'll
discuss he's promised to herself in the
confusion because the franchise all
about Pokemon fights comes out hard
against Pokemon fights because when
they're beating each other up to see
who's the strongest it's fine
but when they're beating each other up
to settle who's the strongest once and
for all
it's suddenly not fine
by not like this now I can see how
horrible fighting really is
I've got one word for you the whole
franchises fighting we are new not a
great plan well we were starting to use
that clip from Warcraft the guy just
going what what huh might be a better
what okay so using using their
superpowers on each other that's okay
punching each other in the face that is
bad it just doesn't track for me because
they're superpowers their moves their
move said if you will includes things
like biting yeah tackle yeah various
types of punch burning kicking burn
lighting them on fire it's really
splitting hairs they're shocking someone
with electricity I think the Japanese
version is more like why are they like
it makes a bigger deal out of one being
clones and one being like natural born
and it's like those they shouldn't be
fighting each other just because one's a
clone one is like a all-natural pokemon
but I think that that was too nuanced of
a point and also it doesn't make the
most sense either to make it to the
translation so they're just like
Fighting's bad right in our kids are
fighting the anime hey yeah for kids
entertainment thank you for the dub keep
going literally for number four because
that may not be the best introduction to
Pokemon anime or even Pokemon anime but
the soundtrack the perfect crash score
we probably should have discussed cuz I
didn't give the note or anything they
just threw DBZ in there what do you
think is the best introduction to anime
jo Nana man you know what not Dragon
Ball Z I think unless you were like on
the Dragon Ball Z train from the very
beginning it had to be it was all that I
could watch cuz it was all but was on TV
after school yeah Cowboy Bebop
maybe it's good contained Full Metal
Alchemist
there maybe that's at least like a good
balance of like fun and action
oh no no no especially I heard endgame
made a few dollars my hero academia I
think is probably the best like jump in
got it all right yeah [ __ ] jokes okay
well imagine that instead of Goku in
that shot and keep going
in early 2000s pop music Britney
Christina NSYNC and 98 degrees
Wow I should really just watch spirited
away it's - story
this animation casual rapper - no one
writes for free I like jords their tiny
paws - where that's obviously referenced
for those that don't know - Pokemon the
original game where you go up and so
you're walking from town to town and
just people just start fighting you
you know if they catch your eyesight
they walk up and like I challenge you or
whatever and they say challenge with
Pokemon they don't punch you know they
always say something before you fight
they'll go like you're in my way let's
fight every whatever else just one kid
just walks up doing this
I like shorts they're comfy and easy to
wear you have to fight you feel really
bad for the kid he's special
he's a special boy it's not looking to
fight he's just full of joy he's just
happy to have his shorts and feels
breeze um oh I know a Pokemon thing mmm
lavender town that's a town yeah yeah
isn't it like in one of the games like
it got pulled out of the game but it was
like it so that's a spooky one yeah else
in it yeah yeah I think there's some
whole thing about like like a mountain
MK ULTRA fan mom is like wearing the
scala for children and like or ya know
it's an MKULTRA thing yeah that's like
most things that's canon yeah that's
absolutely canon yeah Denver Airport
look into it okay
keep coming rock-hard Yocum X Garfield
and friends
and Jordan peels eyes so also pause we
should also thank Danielle who helped
write this big time and also not in
today
so I lost everyone lost everyone it's
it's down to two of the four and Dan on
this one I mean he probably said some
some stuff but he was just like I don't
know what that is
dan is buried in numbers - sure Oh
Harding's gonna be a just a doozy he's
gonna chart his chart attack is super
effective yeah there you go
but weak against role types Oh clever
that works the first movie you saw when
you were eight true I wonder if the
subversion makes more sense no yeah the
subversion has a big big long intro
about the scientist who creates Mewtwo
who creates the clone he's like part of
this larger project to then clone his
daughter from like but he's somehow like
created a facsimile of like her memories
and her personality in like virtual
space and like making a cloned Pokemon
out of you two is like step one and like
then step two is his daughter and got it
probably smart to cut because they
really abandon that like Mewtwo breaks
out and that's kind of the last you'll
hear about them but then mu at the end
the innocent little playful one yeah
he's like he's making us all squeaky
noises at the end and and you know they
me out with the cat they're like what's
he saying in mouth is like in the
American one oh he's saying like you we
should all stop fighting and lay down
our arms or whatever add with Japanese
but like what's he saying clones are an
abomination
he's here to restore the natural order
like wow okay just cutting right to the
point
so those are the main differences that I
noticed yes you should that's why you
should probably watch subtitled anime
which one um which one does Pikachu talk
in that made everyone very upset
yeah doesn't he say like it's not this
movie
am I getting the mixed up no it's not mm
yeah maybe I don't know remember it
happened and people were very upset yeah
I mean it has some horrifying
implications that like we could talk the
whole time but they ass just plain dumb
Jase weird I don't know I mean I get it
the moment that they find out that he
speaks English like they're gonna come
at you know there he's got to keep that
down low otherwise people are gonna take
even more advantage of them yeah
absolutely
Oh God one that when humanity finds out
that you can harvest Pokemon tears for
eternal life oh man is going to be a
thank God they all got in the tier
Factory yeah thank God exactly oh you
like it blade the blood forms and blade
there's so much yeah hey yeah that's
dark let's see some deleted scenes now I
can see how horrible fighting really is
okay look the message just gets lost in
translation
okay they should just give all the
characters amnesia and forget it ever
happened here because we're here I was
joking
don't actually do that Britney Christina
NSYNC and 98 degrees Wow no wonder they
only had enough money left over for one
CGI door
nailed it though looks so good oh yeah
that one door
it was very 3d everything else I'm kind
of no wonder like this is just a
basically a long episode with no
character development or anything like
that
mmm because imagine if ash had become
like a had ascended to the ranks of like
a Pokemon master and his horny buddy
finally hooked up with somebody in the
nurse you know the the lady did whatever
it is she needs to do to be happy I
don't know the characters very well and
like Team Rocket found their balance and
figured out what they really want and
all this stuff and then someone's like
[Laughter]
did I mean they learned a lesson yeah a
lesson that you would think they would
learn but yeah thank God those NFL
owners came in and snap that memory over
to keep the Pokemon fighting same day
alternate study that finds that it won't
actually get concussions from Andrew you
can't have just Kaepernick and for
Pokemon rights like that'd be a good
show I'd watch that show yeah I would
watch that show yeah would there's more
JT right
maybe nice tour get the story versus the
almost dead choir be gray the aristocrat
killed younger and me I need oh yeah
yeah attack that's on the walls
[Music]
myself I guess that's fun I like it as
the last starring but that is a really
funny like visual yeah pazow well I did
just realize it should have been a geek
chorus because it's a Greek horse yeah
that's probably subconsciously why I
never understood the joke but yes every
chorus would have made more sensitive
yeah well maybe Muller I hope you lived
long and I hope you learned to audience
that's our take on Pokemon so first
perhaps the last we'll see why wasn't it
called the first movie it's very
confusing
you mean yaoi its Mew oh you V yeah a
movie you're right these and other
thoughts will stay private from now on
because we're not gonna talk to me
anymore because otherwise it's it's
really just me and me and I'm old and
Pokemon has moved beyond me but I'm
excited to come back for detective
Pikachu because that actually looks
pretty fun that does look like it could
be a who framed roger rabbit level of
insane although I wish they kept Danny
DeVito I love Ryan Reynolds but
something strikes me as fun totally
Danny DeVito yeah dude yeah next week
we'll be back here for something another
thing that is old and won't die so it
will return as will we next week here on
honest trailer commentaries just our
special jugular
thanks for joining my bite
[Music]
you